this is desmond tutu hearing the news
that nelson mandela would soon be
released
he was seldom one to contain his
feelings it just triggered me off this
tutu's response as head of south
africa's truth and reconciliation
commission on hearing details of
atrocities committed by both sides if
apartheid is not dismantled
then
we
was born in a mining town outside
johannesburg at a time of strict
segregation
things would get much worse as he grew
up
tutu was 17 when the national party came
to power in 1948 racial inequality
became law
apartheid
he'd wanted to be a doctor but became a
teacher instead witnessing first-hand
the government's policy of depriving
black south africans of education
consigning them to servitude
and the protests that followed
like the sharpville massacre in 1960 69
people were killed and most of them were
shot in the back as they were running
away protesting against the past laws i
remember it as a moment when
you realized
that black life was
cheap
tutu must have thought he could do more
in the church he joined the clergy
eventually obtaining high anglican
office as dean of johannesburg and later
archbishop of cape town
it propelled him into the public eye as
an unflinching moral voice
why our struggle is going to succeed
is not just because
of numbers
our struggle is going to succeed because
it is a just struggle
by 1984 desmond tutu had won global
admiration he was awarded the nobel
peace prize
it was the kind of recognition that
south africa's anti-apartheid movement
needed to become a global force for a
very very long time i i did hope
that the world would would hear our plea
and that is why we
urge the world to apply sanctions
archbishop desmond tutu was one of the
world's foremost human rights
campaigners an active member of the
elders in the cause of world peace
remembered as much for his unremitting
optimism and infectious laugh
when he introduced nelson mandela as
south africa's new president in 1994
tutu recalled that he whispered to god
if i die now it would be almost the
perfect moment someone up there
must really have been
on our side of operating for us
when mandela died many worried that
south africa had lost its moral compass
they may now wonder whether it's lost
its guiding light